un petit café maison et hop au travail
un bonheur que vif annie larouche
depuis le début de la pandémie dans les
premières semaines
on dirait que j'ai fait qu'on voit plus
détendu fanny a vite vu le climat
familial change est sorti de la maison
toujours entraîneur regarder la route
c'est un peu plus c'est moins la noce
paraît meilleur dans la maison depuis
son bonheur trouve écho dans une étude
sur le télétravail de l'université de
montréal
pour elle le télétravail c'était une
bonne solution donc elles ont été plus
productive en télétravail
elles veulent continuer à télétravailler
l'engouement est indéniable selon la
chercheuse
son étude englobe plus de 7000
répondants principalement du québec et
de la france
le télétravail a la cote auprès de
certains types d'employés surtout quand
ils ont un travail qui est plutôt
autonome avec un peu moins
d'interdépendance avec d'autres
collègues au sein de plus petites
équipes et dans les plus grandes
entreprises mais il est moins apprécié
par d'autres quand le télétravail a
affecté les tâches les personnes en
général ont plutôt manifesté une
réticence
donc on a vu un peu son travail être
dénaturée toujours selon cette étude les
femmes se sentent plus isolé que les
hommes en télétravail un isolement
social mais également organisationnel
les femmes sont déjà dans des postes
moins visibles sont déjà dans des
secteurs qui sont où elles sont sous
représentés donc c'est pas le
télétravail qui va corriger la situation
le télétravail risque peut-être
d'empirer la situation
un défi pour les gestionnaires on sait
aujourd'hui qu'elle prenne une part bien
plus importante que les hommes dans la
conciliation famille travail
comment est-ce qu'on va s'assurer de
leur quart de garantir de leur proposer
des opportunités professionnelles
le télétravail un frein à la carrière
des femmes
la professeure ou hec donne l'exemple de
la recherche universitaire au printemps
2020 plus de mensonges d'articles que en
2019 alors que c'est une diminution pour
les femmes
des conséquences qui pourraient nuire à
long terme à la parité sur le marché du
travail ici marie josée paquet comme
radio canada montréal